Adobe is a brand that pretty much
everyone has heard of because of their
popular programs like Photoshop Premiere
Pro and of course PDF but how are they
able to dominate the market when there
are several worthy opponents like Sony
Vegas from Sony and Final Cut Pro from
Apple make sure stick around till the
end to find out welcome to Hari salaries
so Adobe was established in John Warnock
sooraj by John Warnock and Charles Jeske
in December of 1982 in Mountain View
California
they named the company after the Adobe
Creek that ran behind John Warnock's
house Steve Jobs saw huge potential in
the company right off the bat and he
wanted to buy it for five million
dollars but of course the two men
refused but investors really urged him
to make a deal with Steve Jobs
so eventually did did make a deal they
sold 19% of the company a Steve Jobs at
five times the company's valuation they
also worked out a five-year licensing
deal with them for PostScript and with
this huge investment from Steve Jobs
this company became the first company in
Silicon Valley to become profitable
after the very first year they had a
couple of ideas from what they wanted to
do
for example they thought upgrading
coffee service business or a turnkey
system for office printers but they
ended up designing and developing
specialized printing software
they developed PostScript which became
the world's first truly international
standard for computer printing this is
because they had algorithms that
described letter forms in several
different languages and by 1987 both
group became the industry standard
printer language they had over 400
third-party software programs and
license agreements with 19 printer
companies the first product that I came
out with after PostScript was digital
fonts it released a proprietary format
type 1 now at least a competing standard
true type but true type was more
scalable had more precise control and as
a result Apple's able to license it to
Microsoft in the mid 1980s Adobe entered
the consumer market releasing
illustrator we said back to a base
drawing program
traitor was action and result of their
in-house fog developing program and all
of this really popularized PostScript
enabled laser printers and in August of
1986 Adobe entered Nasdaq and went
public and just a couple of years later
in 1989 they would come out with their
flagship product their graphic editing
software Photoshop in 1991
he'll come out with Adobe Premiere which
would later be rebranded as Premiere Pro
in 2003 and over next couple of years
they would go on an acquiring spree
acquiring OCR systems
Aldus laser tools framed technology
corporation açelya and many more in 1993
they were introduced PDF and Adobe
Acrobat and Reader software PDF is now
an international standard we have all
definitely used it one time or another
they continue to add programs like After
Effects and by a big competitors like
Macromedia 2005 and this is how I became
the Adobe that we know today one of the
biggest advantages that Dobby has over
its competitors is the monthly fee elf
introduced through Creative Cloud to get
access to Adobe software legally you
have to pay twenty one dollars per month
for a software of your choice or fifty
three dollars a month for all of the
software's that they offer with your
student you can get a fast disc Ananda
and get all the software for just Y
dollars mobile this is a lot of dobut to
make their revenue much more predictable
and stable as well now the removal of
licenses that you can use forever
probably pushed away a lot of customers
but at the same time this is so much
better for the company in terms of long
term growth this has allowed them to
actually grow their revenue and there is
a role model in the industry for the
most seamless transition from licensing
to subscription-based services some
competitors are following along on this
track so when you still offer Sony Vegas
Pro for purchase but they also offer
sony vegas pro 365 for $17 a month
slightly undercutting Adobe's prices by
Apple I still stuck to the one-time
purchase for Final Cut Pro so that is an
advantage for Apple but as for Adobe
this in a locked
to make a lot more money especially off
of long term users who have used the
program for several years these users
will pay more than what they would have
paid for licenses in just a couple years
I do think this does make sense as Adobe
continuously updates and provides
services or licensed software so it does
make sense for them to expect the
consumers to pay a consistent P and this
benefits to consumers as well you can
always have the newest most update
software that they have like back then
you would have that license to just want
software like you would own Adobe
Premiere Pro 2006 cc or cs6 but with the
Creative Cloud you get every new
iteration of the software which is
really nice so there are definite pros
and cons to service but was done a right
choice for Adobe Adobe has an extensive
suite that works together seamlessly
from Photoshop to Premiere Pro to After
Effects to illustrator to media encoder
there's so many programs offered by
Adobe other programs don't ask a wide
array of other programs that complement
them like Adobe does for example Sony
Vegas doesn't have a photo editing
software that goes along with it also
all of this complementing programs on
Adobe are also top-of-the-line programs
and the transition is so fluid you can
do the bulk of the editing in Premiere
Pro and the Nats and special effects
using After Effects and it may be go
into Adobe stock and get some photos
they edit in Photoshop and then put back
into Premiere Pro the possibilities of
these programs in conjunction is truly
endless no other option gives you such a
diverse range of products as Adobe does
and this gives Adobe a significant edge
over the competition and that dopey
suite is very easy learning and it's not
just because it's straightforward there
is a large plethora of videos and soft
help articles on how to use this
software Sony Vegas and Final Cut Pro
will have nearly as many self-help
resources as Premiere Pro does like how
to use a green screen how to remove
background noise how to make transitions
there's so many resources for all of
these and all Adobe programs are pretty
self-explanatory if you dig around for a
couple of hours you're sure to be able
to figure
how to do the basic stuff and you can
learn the more complex stuff online for
free and this ease of using great
extensive suite really makes it hard for
people leave and creates a great brand
loyalty these elements convince many
people to deal with the subscription
piece and gets many new people to try
these programs as well and Adobe
software is also more compatible than
their competitors and they work on Mac
OS and Windows
now this compatibility really wouldn't
matter for most categories like gaming
if you're a game developer it really
doesn't matter if you offer your
software on a Mac OS in the creative
space up to 50% of users used Mac OS and
as a result it is very beneficial for
Adobe to offer both options
Final Cut pros only available Apple
devices but you can't get it running on
macintoshes as well and sony vegas pro
there's only available on windows you
can't run around mac OS this gives adobe
premier pro the advantage in both
systems as they are the only other
popular choice there are one of two
major options for both operating systems
and this is really beneficial for adobe
this means that people who have a
Windows computer and don't like Sony
Vegas will choose Premiere Pro the same
thing with Mac people who have a Mac and
don't like Final Cut Pro will choose
Premiere Pro and this gives Adobe a lot
more opportunity when compared to their
competitors and it's not just video
editing software all the programs are
part of the Adobe suite who have
competitors who don't offer on both
operating systems gives Adobe advantage
not to mention all the people who might
have Windows computer at home and have a
MacBook on their go these people will
definitely for an option that's
compatible with both operating systems
as it is evident Dobies compatibility
with mac OS and windows really gives
them an edge adobe is a pioneer in a
creative space and have truly
revolutionized up content is created
across the web this is evident and how
recognizable their programs are
especially Photoshop and the PDF file
format they're easy to learn software
superior compatibility extensive suite
and monthly fees through Creative Cloud
have really allowed
to become the dominant player in this
realm and continue to grow rapidly it's
no wonder why I've dopiest worth over
100 billion dollars as they are sure to
be part of all of our futures but that's
all I have for you guys on Adobe I
should comment down below what company
you would like me to cover next also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing if
you'd like to see more videos just like
this one bye :
I'm Horning I'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]